So, here's the story. A few years into
my career, I knew After Effects inside
and out. I was good at After Effects.
But my work just did not look like the
stuff the best artists were doing. And
frankly, I had no idea why. I'd spent a
lot of time watching tutorials on
specific looks and searching for effects
and plugins to make my work look better.
This was the wrong approach. And as a
result, I ended up opening After Effects
for every new project and then sitting
there with a pit in my stomach, hoping
that by the end of the project, I'd
somehow find good animation by nudging
the key frames around a whole bunch. And
if this sounds familiar, you may be like
I was a motion designer with no
background in motion. The good news is
there is a solution. Learn to animate.
Animation Boot Camp focuses on the craft
and fundamentals of animation, then
shows you how to apply those principles
and techniques like a motion designer.
You'll learn about timing, spacing,
arcs, anticipations, overshoots,
follow-through, squash, and stretch. You
will become very close with the graph
editor. And then you'll learn some
advanced strategies to help you
choreograph complex animation with tons
of layers and multiple shots. And in the
end, you'll have the opportunity to test
your new skills on a project designed by
the legendary studio, Ordinary Folk.
Along the way, you'll make a ton of new
animation buddies in the School of
Motion online community, and you'll be
getting personalized, detailed feedback
on the animations you're completing from
a professional motion designer who will
push and encourage youth. Now, do not
take this class if you're looking for an
easy fix. This class is intense, but if
you're up for the challenge, the results
our students have gotten from the course
speak for themselves. I could not
recommend it enough. I love animation
boot camp. It's the best. It didn't just
take me from like 0 to 10 or 0 to 100.
Took me from like zero to a thousand.
It's been the best learning experience
I've ever had in my life. And it is
completely changed everything for me. If
you want to level up your skills and
level up your confidence and your
career, just go just do it. Let our team
know if you have any questions about
Animation Boot Camp or any of our other
motion design training. I look forward
to seeing you in boot camp and good
luck.